[Musique]
et ce soir émission de folie encore les
chéris il y aura les cas tiers de jean
luc lemoine il y aura camille combal des
20h01 20h02 voilà je vous le dis va
arriver très très tôt camille il y aura
bien sûr du j'ai kiffé j'ai pas kiffer
on aura bien sûr des scoops médias et on
a une petite surprise pour vous puisque
on sait mercredi aujourd'hui c'est
mercredi le mercredi c'est la journée
des bravos fort et la journée les
enfants des séries et donc on a on a on
a fait appel
en fait aux mini mini chroniqueurs voilà
qui seront là et dans un instant les au
chroniqueur viendront et vont découvrir
ils vont arriver qu'un bandeau ou ce qui
les ont pas vus ils vont découvrir en
direct leur mini e
j'ai hâte qu isabelle morini-bosc pas de
plan pour l'instant les romans dont j'ai
hâte isabelle morini-bosc découvre sa
mini elle
je pense que ça va être le fou rire de
la journée nous avons et nous mini
mathieu applaudissements polis
tu t'appelles bonjour bonjour là bonjour
oui toi tu t'appelles matthieu delormeau
d'accord très bien ça va tu as fait quoi
hier soir alors ça rien fait car était
content d'être ici
oui et non technique ou chroniqueurs
préférés à part toi jean luc jean luc
lemoine damien jean luc lemoine qu'on va
voir dans un instant j'ai hâte aussi que
jean luc lemoine voit son 1000 il pense
qu'on va avoir quelques petits soucis
voilà c'est vrai bien tu as un scoop
médiate a quelque chose aujourd'hui
oui vas-y à quoi bon soir du coup ça tu
te trouves bon comme mathieu ou être
très bien d'accord capucine annabi
capituler avec m
comment ça va capucine ça va bien ma
chérie tu es en forme et avec le fils de
qui en ce moment
faut-il ou non la patience est
influencée j'ai pas tu sais pas j'étais
content d'être là et à première fois en
plein d'apprenants français sa première
fois que tu viens ici comment me maman
m'a dit que c'était toi qui étais là
ouais et va suivre où j'ai dit et je
coule elle vit appel à moi je l'appelle
alors ma mais moi je me souviens prix on
se trouverait plus moi c'est tu sais
comment je m'appelle mois michel drucker
il a mis agathe kate avait cumulé
ligne agathe loclois les fabuleuses
comment ça va agathe bien ça va tu es
content d'être là oui pas fiancés dans
quelle classe
non sans quelques classes et eddy cpb
dont cp3 ipd décédé dans mes temps
quelle classe vraiment cp seulement
passer la gp10 et au savon
et pan cpa et non cpi est énervé en fait
rhône paca ont comparativement bien
mais sympa mais d'abord je les aime pas
laissé faire
non tu les aimes pas je ne sais pas
comment je m'appelle si la noix
c'est vrai bravo ma chérie ça va tu
travailles bien les colle très bien à
jan duthoy
[Musique]
mais nick a pu elle a tous nos calculs
il alla jeu
le mini jean michel maire voit ça va
mais les gens me bien gervais a time of
nantes a pas de meuf non la cage ou non
on a 12 ans 11 11 ans tu m'as dit 12
tout à l'heure tu es aussi mito que
jean-michel d'accord en une minute et ma
famille tôt lui d'accord tu fais quoi
dans la vie
le collège le collège tant que clash
dans quelle classe 6e 6e tuera bien time
of non ya pas de ma france moment non
j'ai bien m'entendre avec la mini agathe
kg content d'être là oui c'est vrai tu
l'aimeras jean michel mr ouai
mais qu'est-ce qu'il ya des grandes
lettres céderait thierry mots min tu
rigoles
ça va tirer tous comme en tant que
classe toi un cd v on aimait comme
d'habitude elle tire toutes ont cédé
[Applaudissements]
la voirie qui tu l'appelles titre et
oddo
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
surtout quand on est très content tu
sois là tu aimes bien thierry moreau tu
le connais thierry moreau pas oui tu es
mauvais gars est-ce que capucine peut se
calmer merci aussi reste que tu as prévu
de toi tu vas finir dans la poubelle
[Applaudissements]
qui écrit p on se calme les deux on se
calme on se calme les chéris d'accord on
se calme citi est ce que tu es une
blague eh oui vas-y au fond de moi ça
dans l'es14 souligné le fonds de brosses
à dents le 14 juillet chez ba ba elle
voit un feu dentifrice
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on a avec nous me gilles verdez
applaudissent aubry
ça bien très bien
alors tu es content d'être là oui tu as
quel âge pas fait cas tu es tout calme
toi mon chéri un oui mais quelle classe
cp c'est que tu travailles bien cpb fait
baisser ses puces et huawei est à gaz et
eau agathe la gamme minis agathe il ya
70 ans épatant cpc ppbe lui lancer pc
non à seppi
[Applaudissements]
alors ma chérie tu vas tu travailles à
l'école oui tu as une fiancée non papa
d'amoureuse nom est content d'être là
oui tu connais gilles verdez oui comment
il est en fait je connais pas ça tu vas
le voir dans l'instant
mini zabel mans
commentaires à mulhouse abel ça va très
bien vous avez quel âge 15 ans quinze
ans ça va vous êtes en classe en
troisième troisième c'est votre vrai
coiffure tout ça non là d'accord en tout
cas ça vous va très bien pour elle et sa
belle morini bosc un petit peu
talentueux travail bien toi ouais là tu
as maté contente d'être avec nous oui tu
connais isabelle multiples moyens pas de
panne ou non c'est vrai que tu connais
mieux de l'équipe
qu'est ce que tu préfères tu devrais
avait pas de faire un petit bisou oui
merci à vous
on a mis les le racket avec nous
nigloland
comment ça va miniers non mien est
content d'être là oui ça va tu aimes
bien la télé ouais tu regardes quoi la
télé dessin animé ouais t'as quel âge
c'est en cette heure de classe je ne
sais pas
c'est pas tes pensées plus belle il
paraît gaucher comme gérard est comme
têtu enfin je pense que c'est dans la
même paix classe de serre elle jurait
l'est les eaux chaudes bas
[Applaudissements]
je m'appelle baisse pas sa garde pour
tenir des cuisines pas condamner
quelqu'un autre moi tout ça soit ya
beaucoup d'amoureux noah c'est vrai moi
c'est vrai qu'on voit dans les vernis à
l'isie montady zammouri amoureuse est à
beaucoup d'amoureux pas beaucoup
d'amoureux oui toi tous les garçons sur
amoureux de toi ouais c'était très très
belle étoile amoureuse d'un garçon
ah oui quand il s'appelle ego hugo et
alors il fait du canot comme ma soeur
enfin elle fait de l'art et alors ici
j'ai l'impression que tu as besoin de me
parler mais je te parle à rouiba vas-y
la fatigue originaire de rigolos et des
temps en temps il est beau il est beau
oui et en plus ma jambe et que je dois
sortir avec lui
nantes est trop petit mais non bah si
elle en a envie mais non il peut pas
taxer tôt
qui pense qu'elle doit sortir avec hugo
babines et mathieu quoi tu te regardes
tu penses mais moi pourquoi parce qu'en
fait avec réseau ni et puis oui comme
commence à perdre ses droits et 5e et
améliorer des braconniers a battu lui
aussi sept ans comme moi c'est bien
dommage web on va voir mais c'est trop
petit c'est trop petit pour moi c'est
trop petit et on a enfin jeux minis jean
luc est avec nous ça va bien bats toi là
tu t'aperçois mini jeanjean exactement
ça va bien tu es très élégant merci j'ai
très beau si vraiment tu as quel âge
qu'allah nous en 12 ans top des classes
qui s'enchaînent cinquième match aura
été encore en sixième savas était
content tu connais jean luc lemoine jean
tu le connais pas non tu va le découvrir
d'accord cela jamais vu si je vais
devenir est en toi tu connais laurent
n'ont même pas et en plus de ça qui a
une marraine sur le sol qu'elles sont
plus ajouté collet ça sent le petit
train culte mais chéri dans un instant
tous vous allez découvrir vos sosie vous
êtes tous les ministres dit kaka ils
vont tous les découvrir
ils les ont pas vus encore en leurs amis
ddd il va là des trucs là sur les yeux
pour qu'ils ne voient pas oui
nous transformerons
[Applaudissements]
bien au caire et franchement les baby
feet comment tu t'appelles
en fait elle enfin ça va tu as quel âge
navré il est pas bon raphaël agathe
agathe tu te calmes il est pas bon à
peine il est bon la bicici d'accord à
vis très bien d'accord mais on se calme
avec les saucisses la déchirer l'accord
les merguez l'accord les saucisses non
ok on se calme dans un instant ils
découvriront les chéris découvriront
leur mini sosie ils sont tous avec nous
il y aura bien sûr et nohra il y aura
bien sûr gilles verdez et isabelle
morini-bosc j'ai hâte qu'elle retourne
qu'elle trouve son essence
[Applaudissements]
autre combat l'instant les chéris y
verront leurs sosies après on prendra
une émission dormael a tout de suite mis
de côté
[Applaudissements]